there are many words to describe Martin
reckless Larsson prodigy leader LCS
champion even at only 20 years old
reckless has had quite a journey in his
eSports career through success and
struggle highs and lows this is his
story
[Music]
necklace was born on September 20th 1996
in his early years reckless was a
talented soccer player and looked to be
heading towards the path of a pro
athlete however when he was 14 he
injured his knee and sidelined from the
pitch played league of legends for the
first time he was instantly hooked and
quickly rose through the ranks in
soloqueue gaining the notice of a number
of proteins already hailed as a rare
talent wreckless had a chance to
substitute on teams such as sk gaming
and team black with the latter he
attended the 2012 MLG pro circuit summer
arena and got his first taste of
high-level competition incensed against
azubu blaze team solomid and team curse
in november of 2012 just past his 16th
birthday he was picked up by fnatic as
their starting ad carry becoming one of
league's youngest pro players ever I
didn't take it like SuperDuper serious
but once they invited me to go down to
the house it was like a very good
feeling for me because I felt like I
could leave school behind and take the
chance of going there and like meshing
well with the guys and just being a good
player in general after his arrival
fnatic won three tournaments during
November and December of 2012 the raid
called dominance 1 Dreamhack winter 2012
and the Thor open 2012 fnatic goes home
with the win from the floor open ten
thousand dollars in their pocket during
this time they also had impressive
finishes at larger international
tournaments taking second at the
legendary IGN pro league season five
behind team week and IEM season seven in
Cologne
further hyping up recklessness already
impressive reputation and SK tally
called t1 are going to win it
with his career already off to a flying
start
reckless would encounter his first
obstacle with the creation of the LCS
under LCS rules reckless was a year too
young to play for fnatic in December
2013 he was removed from the main roster
to later be replaced by yellow star as
starting ad carry with yellow star
fnatic successfully qualified for the
first season of the LCS meaning that
reckless would have to wait a full year
before he could rejoin unable to play
with fnatic but not wanting his skill to
rust reckless found a new home playing
alongside Young Buck Cao tired unlimited
and shook the roster was quickly picked
up by the copenhagen wolves and it was
agreed that reckless would play for the
team on loan from fnatic until he was
able to rejoin the team he has been
locked down from Nami that's going to be
a beautiful pentakill and while once
again reckless just goes huge with the
otherwise strong roster bolstered by
recklessness tremendous skill the
copenhagen wolves rocketed to the top of
the Challenger scene they were a terror
at any event they attended taking first
at Dreamhack summer 2013 and countless
EU west challenger series cups later in
the year
reckless held the Wolves earn a spot in
the 2014 PU LCS spring promotion
tournament on the copenhagen wolves they
were the big favourite coming into this
game once again and they are going to
win nut position in the spring
promotional tournament and dreams of
becoming
yes seemed very much alive right now and
I think right now they got to be very
happy themselves but I'll feel a little
bit worried because they already know
breakfast is laughing pathetic they
threw out his time with the wolves
reckless was a dominant force and while
fnatic had taken back-to-back LCF titles
and third to fourth at Worlds in 2013
without him anticipation for his return
was building on November 22nd reckless
was officially made of starting ad carry
on fnatic and just a day later he made
his comeback at IEM season 8 Cologne
against counter logic gaming Mitch made
the point that you know a bit of why
they have been found and I wanted to
wind down after Worlds perfectly
acceptable it was but they come back now
it's difficult to measure where they're
going to go up against CLG at the same
time though it's still fnatic they've
been together for so long yes maybe
they're swapping in records but he's
been living with them like training with
them following them around for so long
they've been playing dual EQ I know
yellow star in records I've been playing
so many games together so they're
fine-tuned already if you play fnatic
what can we expect from that matchup
down the lane Assam that's all you can
expect a one-sided talk like me enough
are really good and like I said I think
Bret was kind of already broke up the
red meanwhile yellow saw teleport the
flash comes in I've don't believe come
to UDP rectus is gonna turn around he
just wants to get to kill us a great big
breakfast right back
that last fire that just happened leaked
he tried to also breakfast you try to
hold him down what it's sort of tougher
than that but it didn't matter expecting
he got the black shield up she was able
just alive probably take that victory
variables fnatic
he had already proven himself time and
time again on the International Circuit
and in the Challenger scene now it was
time for reckless to show the LCS what
he was made of his debut was better than
anyone could have hoped for
and now yeah this off gets all the
toilets Howard I'm enjoying some of the
top it this could turn out horribly both
fnatic
oh and diamond get splashed away by
records but County closed the gap is
going towards wrecked if he should know
Clary a fight whilst a manic had some
bumps along the way in reckless rookie
LCS split the team surged into the
playoffs and defeated Alliance and
sk-gaming to claim the title you might
chase off the woman and the surrender
does the rest of oh but nothing are
there was a world champion they are
champion of these great riches now of
course build a new guy in fnatic for
coming in here performing solo the
entire season and he didn't step down to
play object all the while reckless was
impressive and he was named the playoff
MVP a week showing at all-stars Paris
2014 lead fnatic into a poor start in
the summer split the page you can see
the Nexus turrets are tumbling and SK
Telecom will reach the final what a
fantastic performance when page that I'm
on no doubt about it
26 minutes lines in game and our
dominant if announcing tomorrow where to
fnatic go from here that's the question
they've won the European split three
times running now clearly they are the
number one coming York I think they need
to get out of there their slump it's
hard to say that they are in a slump
because they did win the European split
but they started off so strong they
almost need to do with you too sometimes
I don't want to say they eat a roster
change but they need a change of
sometime they struggle to find
consistent winds until the back half of
the split when they once again served
with a record of 12 and 2 and the final
five weeks fanatics bot lane in
particular came alive down the stretch
and reckless is vain and Lucien
decimated the opposition if this goes up
connects is done by powers Institute in
the background and young buck is going
to get - to Chum the waters connection
will like the past target possible the
explorer's was used on Pegasus
[Applause]
breakfast with a pentakill the summer
flip despite their good form leading
into the playoffs fnatic barely scrape
by team Roccat three and two in the
semi-finals and fell to their main rival
alliance in the final but nothing Aussie
thrown as the champions of you're the
new king o goes to the World
Championship as the number one thing it
was fanatics first time with the split
title world's 2014 did not go much
better for reckless and fnatic while
they had some thrilling games a
heartbreaker against oMG was a dagger
for their hopes of making it out of the
groove in angels on the side of fnatic
they sit on those death spawn as their
Nexus goes down and oMG picks up the win
over fnatic the back-to-back
international disappointments combined
with their loss to Alliance prompted the
members of fnatic to seek something new
with cyanide deciding to retire expec a
and so as left the team and found origin
with his eSports family scattered and
staring down either a significant
rebuild on fnatic or a risk pursuing a
spot on Origen wreckless decided that a
move to a more established roster was
the best idea on November 24th 2014 he
transferred to Alliance later rebranded
as elements while fanatic fans were
devastated by the news the elements
super team was looking stronger than
ever
unfortunately recklessness debut on the
new team was ugly they will take this
win and deny playoff some elements and
reckless absolutely not how it ends for
elements they owe lose reckless again
after all that insult to injury the next
is going down fnatic have denied element
of playoff spot
despite coming off of a win in the last
split and receiving an upgrade at ad
carry elements was a train wreck
struggling with roster issues from day
one over the course of the spring split
they had over a half-a-dozen roster
swaps resulting in a seventh place
finish
avoiding relegation but also missing out
on playoffs yes yes this was the game
that absolutely cost elements their
chances but it has been a disappointing
split for the entirety of the year
constantly dropping games they had all
those roster shuffles miffed going to
coach wicked out Kevin and Kevin out
wicked back none of the players of
teamwork or team play ever settled into
a routine meanwhile soon annex revamp
roster was as strong as ever taking
first overall in the split and
impressing at the midseason Invitational
I do love the fight that fnatic put up I
love their aggression these guys did not
want to go down the members of elements
pointed the finger at poor communication
and a lack of cohesion for their issues
and reckless was vocal in his
displeasure even making controversial
social media posts about the poor state
of the team and organization things
didn't go up they they were found to be
I think that's just because sometimes
things just work out you know it doesn't
have to be someone being a major problem
or anything just sometimes the puzzle
doesn't work together we were being put
in a very tough spot and elements we
were like fighting for relegation and we
were on the edge of like having to work
with each other even if it didn't work
you know like we were forced to do that
because else would be relegated when
fnatic offered reckless a chance to
return to the team he jumped at the
chance safe to say he made the right
call fnatic finished the season with a
perfect 18 no record in the regular
season becoming the first team in LCS
history to do so lair of the Sirian care
of the final is reckless I mean it was
incredibly back and forth but in some
games the ad carries absolutely made the
difference
Penn secured that of course versus it
over the edge as well
before them downs liftalot connect as
well and reckless plus that secure I got
on that that's a double he's looking for
go girl at the triple he's looking for
for that's the quadrant he will get it
three step forward looking for a record
it's on fire
fnatic going to Worlds 2015 red hot and
with a mountain of fan support behind
them despite a shaky start to the group
stage a three no final day in edit
fnatic a spot in the quarterfinals where
they upset a Chinese champion Edward
gaming 3a no to advance the run to the
Nexus synaptic Louis thought for semi
finals the ugly team this is like three
times in the World Championship it was
at Worlds 2015 that recklessness pocket
ad cannon began to appear which has
since become a signature of his play
that an ad cannon it is oh my good as
one of my absolute all-time favorite
place so far up they'll have that lining
Ruskin repositioned very quickly at
yellow so he's gonna find limitation all
that going out of the way the dog
fighting the Trump is going to go down
limited to get flashed on reckless
graphic Yolanda and
by 9:00 please reckless joining agrestic
um stuff bud is actually the Bilgewater
Cutlass is the thought comes in as well
lemonnation done done for a long time in
reckless just falling while they lost
three notes to the two tires in the
semi-finals reckless and fanatic had
done Europe proud and were returning
home as heroes sadly just as things were
once again on the up and up for reckless
another obstacle presented itself rain
over honey and yellow star all left the
team and moved to North America leaving
fnatic to rebuild a roster around
reckless and febiven the weight of
leadership
once resting on yellow star shoulders
now fell to reckless as he was asked to
lead fnatic into the new era I feel like
this year I have much more space much
more responsibility not only in the game
or anything of the game related on first
level but also just in the house here I
feel like people are looking up to me
more now than they did on previous times
therefore I've actually been trying to
in some ways mimic what Bora did last
year with waking up early big showing up
first perhaps leading an example in some
ways despite his experience it was still
a heavy bird doubly so considering he
had to add shotcalling to his pile of
responsibilities I want to grow into
captain role more not done so far I feel
like with only one month of time doing
so it's been a tough journey it's been
hard to adapt to the role although
adding talent like spirit in the
offseason the new roster did not get off
to a strong start their debut at IEM
cologne was disappointing and were
inconsistent during the spring split
there's the unbearable force there it's
the flip is going in gets the knock up
WC GT can come in as well gobble-gobble
will not connect the way they wanted to
do TCG on the rest of the team's leading
the charge to try and take down
the eating does not go down it's only
reckless after costume that's gonna be a
better day
[ __ ] Eugene Wrayburn we knew that
shotcalling was going to be an issue
rather than said reckless and I are
stepping up we're gonna fill the shoes
that that yellow star left behind it
carries over into Game three and they're
just going on to one reckless is bot
Lane synergy with new support noxee AK
was poor improvement we're just not
there the improvement like what's so
hard for us to have that jungle supports
energy and have that eighty to eighty
supports energy that we wanted with no
sir so therefore we just felt like a
change was needed so it wasn't like
things were super duper bad with knock
SEC I would say it was still more than
fine but we just felt like if we were to
make a replacement there and perhaps
perhaps have more of a group of five we
would have higher chances of reaching a
higher state of the team in time for I
am in type of playoffs and ultimately as
well as the world working Swedish
support cly was brought in with clay
fern attic had a strong showing at IEM
katowice finishing second on the back of
recklessness near undefeated gin oh it's
so low it's going in for the steal
phonetic roll just so low they tried to
thank you for so long it kicks without a
man they do finally look
there we go reckless what's the damage
more going to get rid taken down
eventually there it is right this
finishes evolved get himself the triple
but oh my word was that close for
financed by the end of the season they
slipped into the playoffs in six
defeating vitality in the first round
but losing to g2 esports in the
semifinals EG so red-hot rookies will
knock off the reigning champ and route
to us spring showed out and rotterdam
following the frustrating season yellow
star returned to the bot lane with
reckless but while his veteran
leadership was welcome it sadly did
little to salvage fnatic the team would
make the playoffs but would lose in the
semi-finals to h2k gaming with one more
shot at Worlds fnatic lost in the
regional final three and O to the
unicorns of love Nexus is going down
there's nothing left right now fnatic
they're going to get taken out unicorns
they're going to complete this sweet
twenty seven and a half minutes in for a
final showdown crisp line fnatic was
lackluster they failed to pull the
trigger on the key moments and losing
that final game that denies you tend to
go to the World Finals is honestly
heartbreaking so if there's fans out
there for fnatic and any of the teams
that I have missed their spots of Worlds
make sure you reach out to them show you
their support because that's when they
needed the most overall 2016 was a clear
low point in reckless career tasked with
helping rebuilding and lead fnatic the
results were a clear disappointment for
fans and the players alike by the end of
the year
many were questioning if reckless was
the right man for the job unfortunately
things weren't about to get any easier
4/5 of the roster left prior to the 2017
spring split with yellow star heading
into retirement
s'vivon back to h2k and Gansu and spirit
back to korea and yeah that that's just
Michael I want to I want to win the
world because I've been so close already
and I know how to get there and I know
also how to not get there because I went
just facing up to 16 down so now it's
time to go free
and if I go down then there's really
something wrong with wreckless as the
only remaining member another full
rebuild was surely a daunting task the
new fnatic welcome back so as who had
played with Regulus during the glory
days of 2013 to 2014 the team also
brought in veteran jungler amazing and
former SK gaming mid laner jerseys at
support rounding out the roster was the
biggest gamble of the lots rookie mid
laner caps a talented but generally
inexperienced player the new fnatic
roster was placed into Group a of the
spring split amongst the stiff
competition of g2 eSports and misfits
while caps had a breakout season and
wreckless was once again turning heads
reclaiming his reputation as a fearsome
ad carry with teams often respect
banning his Kennan it's all too easy for
our recklessly pin Hassan skip and
jumping all over the place and goes
godlike during this time records became
vocal about his struggles with his
mental health the pressures of
professional play and leadership weighed
heavily on him and as he had grown as
both a player and a person he was more
accepting of the knees to discuss these
sensitive issues he decided to take the
offseason to recenter himself with a
trip home to sweden and sharing he head
into the summer split as strong as
possible with reckless focused and
motivated the 2017 summer split has been
an excellent return to the forum
fanatics to the top their group and
reckless is once again making his mark
as one of the most gifted ad carries
Europe has ever seen jezus waiting in
the lane OG baby
here we go reckless delivering the other
is going down too reckless with the
Kenan right you got to give him props
for playing this champion out to
wellness 10 could be in trouble he
stunned up by the shuriken at the flash
out followed by reckless the man has no
fear
I think if things ever work second back
in at the drug resistance we know how it
all ended back to live he actually never
stopped reckless this time is on his own
or is he in so ID tag it in and now the
tables are turned tricks out of there
and records on a killing spree 3 & 0
looking for expect it's never just one
member of fanatic like that para it's
never done one member redemption as well
from Kansas and now we come to today
through the ups and downs highs and lows
reckless has emerged as a leader a
figurehead for the lead community and
the face of a franchise each step along
the way was needed from his early
successes to the difficulties of loss
and the struggle of leadership to bring
him to this moment and still the journey
is far from over
after all there's still a Eve throne to
reclaim and after that so much more
[Music]
thanks for watching our telling a
reckless story we loved producing these
videos and hope you enjoy them just as
much is there a story you think that we
should tell leave your suggestions in
the comments below and be sure to
subscribe for more great content
[Music]